autre sujet je te taquine on va parler
de nutrition depuis quelques années
maintenant les français font vous l'avez
compris bien plus attention à leur
alimentation
on dit qu'on mange sainement qu'on mange
bio cependant de nombreux articles
vendus en magasin trompent le
consommateur en adoptant un packaging
qui reprend alors on va dire plus ou
moins spontanément et les codes et les
couleurs de ses produits et on a vu ça
dans révélations sur rmc story pourtant
ce client vient bien d'acheter deux
paquets de gâteaux conventionnel
convaincus qu'ils sont bio à cause des
affiches posées par le magasin la
confusion entre bio et non bio se joue
aussi sur les emballages
vous avez un environnement vert vous
avez 2 2 feuilles comme ça qui évoque le
logo bio d'agriculture biologique
européen
le vrai problème réside dans une
nouvelle appellation 0 résidus de
pesticides ce qu'essaye de faire ces
professionnels c'est de contourner les
exigences du label bio donc le
consommateur peut penser quand ils
voient un produit comme ça que c'est
équivalent un produit bio alors que
c'est pas le cas du tout alors qu'est ce
que vous pensez de on va dire cette
confusion entretenue plus ou moins
sciemment par les industriels
jimmy qu'est ce que vous en pensez alors
c'est vrai que c'est de la confusion
simple excroquerie canton dans certains
magasins bio ou nous vend des articles
qui ne sont pas bio mais comme ils sont
dans l'enseigne on pense que c'est bio
mais sans le dire les cartes packaging
tout vert avec un logo les consommateurs
faire en sorte qu'ils payent plus en
revanche c'est pas parce que c'est bio
que c'est bien du tri tivement un
exemple tout bête
les galettes de riz que vous retrouvez
dans certains rayons bio c'est bourré de
sucre en revanche acheter une pomme qui
n'est pas forcément bio mais vous allez
bien lavés épluchés et bien c'est
peut-être mieux d'acheter la pomme qui
est pas bio d'accord ça parce que c'est
bien que vous allez bien manger sur le
bio en faisant quoi qu'il arrive
oui donc en gros ça nous coûte de
brahimi mais en plus c'est pas forcément
bon pour la santé le bio c'est gros
c'est ce qu'est en train de oui et puis
non mais c'est surtout que là on nous
vend des articles comme un temps bio ça
sans dire que c'est bio tout en disant
quand même regarder ça à l'air bio
puisque c'est tout en vert et c'est
absolument scandaleux en fait moi ça
m'énerve profondément je suis là en
train de regarder dans les rayons pour
essayer de manger à peu près bien tu
sais que du coup c'est un budget
supplémentaire tâche est le truc est en
fait tu rentres chez toi au final tu
t'es fait berner camp
bon alors non mais comment jambon rien
c'est bien voilà je suis tout faire un
petit jardin bio donc ça change tout je
sais pas ce que vous verrez cette
aventure vous êtes tous très énervé il
n'essaye pas de nous vendre du bio ou de
nous faire croire que c'est du bio il
nous met pas du tout c'est au
consommateur à moins d'être analphabète
de savoir si écrit bios et bios et si ya
pas écrit bio c'est que ces panneaux on
essaye ne soit pas comme m effectivement
si on retourne si on lit mais ce que qui
a le temps quand il se sort du travail
et qu'il a en dix minutes le temps de
faire les courses pour les enfants et
qui se dit je vais rapidement dans un
rayon qui me semble à peu près ou bio et
éthiques
prendre deux trois trucs vite fait et
s'il faut retourner l'étiquette l'iran
tout petits qui en fait non ce n'est pas
du biométhane a essayé de nous faire
croire que c'était du bio qu'un produits
non bio se retrouve dans un rayon bio ça
c'est pas cool mais que ya une confusion
en termes d'éthique est et que le vert
ça représente aussi tout ce qui est
végétal vegan nature sans pesticide est
assez des informations supplémentaires
que le consommateur doit prendre en
compte et c'est à nous d'être un tout
petit peu informés accord écoutez on a
posé la question aux téléspectateurs
laisser berner par par des ventes a fait
on a posé la question des spectateurs ce
que vous faites confiance aux étiquettes
bio sur les packagings oui les yeux
fermés au nom je vérifie 90% ils ne sont
pas dupes ou téléspectateurs ils
vérifient à 90 content c'est avec voilà